we have uh people on our streets
jihadists and their fellow Travelers
calling for the murder of Jewish people
the destruction of the Jewish State and
the destruction of the British State
well I say in that situation we can
remain hand ringing liberals about this
and say as some let us say not to be too
rude Centrist dads do in some of our
newspapers that we must simply ring our
hands at this and say this is one of the
prices we must pay to remain a liberal
society and I say screw
that Douglas you wrote The Strange death
of Europe are you happy
now um no I mean it's it's uh a book I
regard as being an accurate description
of events as they were and an accurate
prediction of events as they've turned
out but um it gives me no pleasure
whatsoever and I knew it never would uh
I knew it would never be one of those
things where I'd Pat myself on the back
and say Well done for getting that right
I don't feel that at all in fact I said
when the strange death of Europe
immigration identity and Islam as as a
subtitle came out I said that it's my
fervent desire that this book proves to
be
wrong re you said that to me in an
interview about that and you wanted it
to be wrong alas here we are um what do
you make of of the warnings and the
people because it wasn't just you
obviously one of the most outs spoke of
this but all the people that said we
were going to sort him get here we were
going to I don't know that people
thought we were going to get to the
sheer barbarity and that the defense of
it but that the General State of where
we're at that when I'm quite literally
driving here this morning I ask what I
think is a Hos rally I don't have a
problem making no distinction because I
don't see anyone out there saying they
don't like Kamas sure um but warning I
guess just isn't enough huh uh well it's
a bit worse than that I mean we've been
totally infiltrated in societies like
Britain and we have to De infiltrate our
societies um if we're going to solve
this I mean one could just sit on one's
hands and bemoon it but I don't think we
should I said in the opening lines of
the strange death of Europe that Europe
was committing suicide or at least its
leaders had decided to commit suicide
the question I said is whether or not
the people of Europe decide to go along
with that decision it's my fervent hope
that they do
not uh but the morning that we're
speaking uh we have woken up in London
to see footage of a man in England who
was arrested last night by the
police uh for
what for being one of the thousands of
people on the streets of our cities
calling for Jihad no no no no for being
one of the thousands of people in our
cities calling for the radication of the
Jewish State and indeed the Jewish
people no he was arrested at his home
for posting a video on social media
where he showed all of these Palestinian
flags have been put up in his
neighborhood on the High Street and
saying he didn't like it very
much well it seems that in London at the
moment you are allowed to call for Jihad
you are allowed as happened last night
outside the prime minister's house in
Downing Street to call for violence
against the Jewish people you're allowed
to do that but you are not allowed to
complain about the people doing that and
that runs through every part of our
society now in Britain we have uh people
on our streets jihadists and their
fellow Travelers calling for the murder
of Jewish people the destruction of the
Jewish State and the destruction of the
British State well I say in that
situation we can remain hand ringing
liberals about this and say as some let
us say not to be too rude Centrist dads
do in some of our newspapers that we
must simply ring our hands at this and
say this is one of the prices we must
pay to remain a liberal society and I
say screw that so what do we do with
that because yes we always nail it
better than anybody and before everybody
and everything else but when we had
dinner the other night would a big group
of people listen we got we Whitted it
down to this and we had some more on the
other that side of it saying oh but we
must still protect their PR speech and
everything I think you and I we want to
protect Free Speech as L as as possible
you want Britain to remain liberal in
the true sense but what do you do well
more importantly I want Britain to
remain Britain well said so what do you
do then how how do we deal with this
with will this in calls for genocide and
the liberals who will be genocided next
defending the speech so what do we do
well I say this very carefully um but
with uh as much clarity as I can we have
institutions like the police who are no
longer protecting the
public if the police police cannot
protect the public it will fall to the
Army to protect the public and if the
Army cannot protect the public then the
public will have to learn to protect
themselves and it will go into the hands
of the
public that will be exceptionally
ugly but there are far more people who
despise the jihadists than there are
jihadists so my warning to the
government and to the police is if you
don't sort this out the public have to
sort it out
themselves and
that's that is a situation much to be
feared what do you think the
disconnected I've asked this to several
people inside my chair what do you think
the disconnect is in the west between
the people and the government what is
going on that even in America this
morning I'm watching thousands of people
cross your borders knowing full well
what has happened here and what has
happened in France where is that why is
it that these people is it intentional
is it is it negligence is it it's
different things for different people
yeah some people of course I mean you
have members of Congress in the us as we
know who obviously supportive of Hamas
and obviously supportive of the
eradication of the Jewish State
obviously I mean we should have no
problem about identifying the fact that
people like Yan Omar Rashid Talib and
others uh are simply uh extremists who
wish the eradication of the Jewish State
um and we and America by the way well
the Jewish State first and America Next
of course um these are enemies within uh
we have our own ones in Britain like
this um and as I say what you have to
work out at some point where you're
being uh where your system is being
gamed and it's being gamed in America
it's been gamed much more and it has
been gamed for much longer in the UK but
I mean you see it in things like for
instance the first minister of Scotland
arm a ussef he's married to a
Palestinian she's a particularly um uh
nasty piece of work who has been on the
record before smearing the Jewish state
in all sorts of ways her parents are in
Gaza uh Hamza yusf as far as I can see
is not the first minister of Scotland
he's become the first minister of Gaza
or an ambassador for Gaza or something
like that yeah he thinks Scotland's too
white he thinks also that Scotland
should take in the people of Gaza as
refugees in the in the Scotland of my
youth I think we would have been amazed
at the idea that by the year 2023 we
would have a first Minister calling for
the importing of people from one of the
world's most radical
stats uh not yet States encampments
cities
strips Scotland by the way has only just
come out of several hundred years of
extremely intense political and
religious Warfare yeah the the the the
sulfur of it continues in some of on
some some of The Terraces some of the
football stadiums some of the
streets what an amazing thing in the TW
21st century to import an even worse
religious
conflict but people like hamzi yusf have
um I say it carefully but have
infiltrated our system he does not seem
to be much in bothered by the situation
of the Scottish people and the people of
Glasgow who have one of the lowest uh
life expectancies not just in Britain
but anywhere in Europe he does not seem
to care about that or if he does he does
nothing about it but my word if you look
at his social media proclamations and
everything else you would think that he
was indeed first minister of Gaza this
is a problem that the Scots must sought
out the Scottish electorate must sought
out and indeed the British electorate
but it is very very late in the
day what would be the proper policy so
if putting aside who the politician is
to do it but if if the guy or girl
magically appeared to do what you think
must be done to this project what is it
I mean it's the first thing is the
immediate expulsion of hamas's leaders
in the UK to our enormous shame and I've
written about this for many years again
I've warned about it for many years and
tried to take action about it for many
years but we have people like Muhammad
saala former military leader of Hamas in
the West Bank who lives in North
London uh I'm happy to give his address
out next he lives in North London in a
council house mysteriously paid for
with a very large six-finger donation
from somewhere I wonder
where um he was broadcasting on an ofcom
we have this stupid thing called ofcom
in the UK which is meant to regulate
television channels uh just the other
week the whole of UK melted down because
uh the actor Lawrence fox said the word
shag on GB news about um a very
unpleasant woman who he was rather
perhaps too um Avid in his expressions
of dislike for on there but nevertheless
everyone said oh my God this is an ofcom
regulated channel uh uh can nothing be
done we all had our everyone had their
eyes on the wrong ball of fools in the
UK about this all of the leftists and
the others who thought oh we have to
regulate GB news and offc com meantime
hamaz TV is spewing its hate from London
and Muhammad saal is one of the guests
on it and only earlier this year was
celebrating the murder of Jews on this
offc com regulated Channel and if you
want to have an idea of how bad this is
in the very background of the channel is
a glorious view of Westminster including
the London Eye so this is right in the
heart of London boasting about it I
would have Muhammad saal his citizenship
withdrawn immediately he has no right to
be in my country we have no need of him
can you strip people's citizenship yes
we did it to Isis members Muhammad saalo
is sitting in turkey at the moment um I
submit he should never be allowed to
step foot on British soil or if he does
he is arrested Ed I've written to the
Home Secretary the foreign secretary the
director of public prosecutions the
attorney general and the Prime Minister
last week saying that if they do not
take action against Muhammad saala I
will in a personal
capacity um we get Hamas out
immediately then next we get its
supporters out I have no desire to share
my country with these people it is my
country not
theirs I wish we had about 10,000 more
Douglas Murray's well so do I but I
think we do we've got plenty more people
I'm at the moderate end of what's
coming that that says something um let
me just ask you one other thing since
you do spend a bunch of your time now in
America do you think our systems are a
little better related to dealing with
this that we might because of our
foundational documents and because of
state's rights we might have a little
bit more of a force field against what
seems to be coming I don't know if the
institution so much but some of them are
some of them are woeful some of them are
worse I tell you what what we do have in
America is uh men with some spunk and I
say that with no
inuendo serious yeah
um
truthfulness we were founded on a
revolution and we have
guns um what's more I think that there
hasn't been as much Co of the American
public as there has has been of the
British European public the publics in
Europe have been told to be fearful of
the public the politicians are certainly
fearful of the public and the public
haven't had their voice yet haven't
found it yet they
will um in America people are still much
more willing to stand up personally I've
seen that of course we've all seen it in
footage of things like that glorious
hero in New York the other day working
class blue collar worker American sees
one of these SC scumbags ripping down
posters of want you know wanted posters
missing posters of of abducted Jewish
children sees this scumbag ripping them
down and goes and confronts him himself
a couple of them fantastic Fant that's
the spirit of America I saw one another
one like that just just this morning a
great guy just says you know I don't
want this stuff on my streets I have
some trust still that America has um um
a bit more in the bank than uh than
Britain and Europe but again that'll
change as circumstances change um what I
would say is there's a very obvious
thing that changes around and I will get
in trouble for saying this but let's say
it um once your Muslim population
massively outweighs your Jewish
population you have problems like the
why we do it in the
UK If that is slightly the other way
around as it is currently in America
there's a larger Jewish population than
there is and wasn't population B it goes
another way I enormously admire what
mayor Adams said the other day after the
massacre of
Jews but I also think that it was an
elector isue and I'm I'm not by any
means uh degrading him he has proved a
very fine leader at certain times in New
York but as mayor of New York he gave a
very very good speech in solidarity with
the people of Israel after the massacre
of that people now of course sadik Khan
in London would not do that and that's
partly because he's um obviously like
ham yusf and others he is much more
sympathetic to the Palestinian of course
because he's a Muslim and this is baked
into their blood I mean it is so baked
in this this this dislike of Jews the
hatred of Israel and there's a long
discussion as to why that has that has
happened and how far back it goes what
its Origins are and much more but sadik
Khan would not say what M Adams said
but it is in part also because mayor
Adams needs to be reelected and he knows
that in America certainly New York today
um if you took an anti-israel line it
would still be
disliked by not just Jews in New York
and elsewhere but by non-jews like that
guy in Queens like the guy in Queens the
point is is as many people have said
demographics is
Destiny and if you change the makeup of
your country It Is by no means
inevitable that your country Remains the
Same in fact it's highly likely that it
will be
different dare I end an interview with
Douglas Murray by slightly editing a
quote from Douglas Murray which is the
line that I have repeated to a million
times in my audience has heard it
gajillion times and I always credit you
for it which was that one day The
Barbarians will be at the gate and we'll
be debating what gender pronouns to call
them what if that was slightly edited to
uh fit the current times which is one
day the Barbarian Ian will be at the
gate and we debating how high up on the
neck we will let them behead us that
seems to be where we're at at well you
have you have people sicko weirdo
leftists on social media and elsewhere
debating whether it's accurate to say if
a young woman at the music festival had
the back of her skull smashed off
whether it's accurate to say she was
beheaded or whether it's it's an
inaccuracy and an example of the Israeli
president who said that the girl in
question was decapitated over egging the
pudding we're at a stage in the debate
where we have leftists saying that true
40 babies uh were massacred but they
weren't all beheaded some were partially
beheaded we're at that stage of it um I
don't I I have no more words to these
people I have no more desire to speak
with them or speak to them um they can
all go to hell uh the rest of us have a
lot of work to do if you're looking for
more hon and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
screaming check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell